Wie könnte unsere welt in zehn 20 30 oder 100 jahren aussehen klicks um science-fiction hat ja eine kooperation mit
technology und deren redaktion hatte in diesem sommer schon zum fünften mal junge leute gekürt deren ideen und erfindungen schon in naher zukunft
unser leben hochwahrscheinlich
maßgeblich prägen werden wie sie die zukunft also aus herzlich willkommen bei klick zum science fiction am ende gibt es übrigens ein gratis exemplar
der zeitschrift technology review
Platz fünf internet durch
glasfaserverbindungen deluxe gerettet
glasfaserverbindung haben ein riesiges potenzial und können uns demnächst auf allen endgeräten
videos in kinoqualität liefern oder operation roboter ermöglichen die chirurgen über das internet steuern
doch die große herausforderung bei dem konzept der glasfaserverbindung bestand bislang aus physikalischen hindernissen beispielsweise ist der
frequenzbereich des lichts in dem die daten über die fasern verschickt werden begrenzt und der bereich der
nutzbaren frequenzen geht stück für stück zur neige eine katastrophale situation für die
fernverbindungen die über die unterseekabel zwischen den kontinenten laufen denn sie werden schon sehr bald hoffnungslos
überlastet sein der elektroingenieur von teile aus stuttgart hat eine großartige idee gab
glasfaserverbindung zu optimieren er hat auf dem dilemma herum gedacht dass es eben nicht einfach die lösung sein kann mehr bits pro sekunde
durch die glasfaser zu schicken dazu lädt dafür müsste man die intensität der impulse verstärken das aber führt dazu dass die
lichtsignale sich auf nichtlineare weise verzerrt
bekannt ist dieses problem auch als sogenanntes shannon limit das beschreibt inwieweit eine fehlerfreie
datenübertragung möglich ist und zwar in abhängigkeit von bandbreite und dem signal rausch verhältnis
jetzt aber endlich zu lesen lösungsansatz der dieses limit umgeht der ingenieur hat ein verfahren entwickelt
das die zu erwartenden verzerrung berechnet und die signale so formt dass die steuereffekte
ausgeglichen werden tests zeigen dass die kapazität der glasfasern so um 50 prozent gesteigert werden
ja und damit nicht genug lee hat außerdem ein verfahren entwickelt
mit dem die maximale datenrate in einer frequenz kanal von 40 achtung auf
256 kilobit pro sekunde gesteigert wird und dass tatsächlich das ist weltrekord in den nächsten sieben jahren will die
kapazität von glasfasern um das zehnfache steigern und das ohne zusätzliche kosten platz vier
menschenleben retten blutvergiftung durchgehend analyse auf die spur kommen
blutvergiftungen sind lebensgefährlich pilze gifte bakterien dringend über eine verletzung in den blutkreislauf an und die
entzündungsreaktion die kann dann zu organversagen für
27 millionen menschen sind jedes jahr weltweit betroffen ein drittel davon stirbt der
bioinformatiker philip stephens hat eine idee entwickelt menschenleben zu retten dazu hat er eine software ins leben gerufen die nach
bruchstücken der erreger dna im blut der patienten und patientinnen sucht damit wird dann nicht nur ganz klar
diagnostiziert ob ein mensch betroffen ist sondern auch welcher keinem der auslöser ist gegenmaßnahmen wie eine
antibiotikum gabe können dann zeitnah erfolgen mittlerweile werden schon erste klinische studie und vorbereitet und stevens ist
zuversichtlich die sätze es ist nur der anfang auch anderen
infektionskrankheiten könnte man nämlich so demnächst auf die schliche kommen platz drei
glas aus dem drucker
fredericks vom institute of technology in karlsruhe hat ein material entwickelt das jeweils die besten eigenschaften von glas bzw
kunststoff vereint eine supersache
beispielsweise für die linsen von handykameras ihn bestehen derzeit aus kunststoff dabei wäre quarzglas deutlich besser denn es ist bei temperaturschwankungen
formstabil hoch transparent und knallhart doch der entscheidende nachteil der werkstoff wird erst bei
2000 grad celsius flüssig was es unmöglich macht große mengen an winzigen glas erzeugnissen günstig herzustellen das neu entwickelte
material hat klar summe genannt es lässt sich
verarbeiten wie kunststoff hat aber dennoch die idealen eigenschaften von glas dazu kurz das ist ein kunststoff in dem ein hoher anteil an glas
nanopartikeln eingelagert ist bestrahlt man das material mit licht verbinden sich die kunststoff moleküle und werden fest
die flüssigkeit wird in
handelsüblichen 3d stereo lithografie druckern verwendet der kunststoff verdampft dann bei rund 600 grad in einem
hochtemperatur ofen und die glas nanopartikel werden versöhnt hat also sie verschmelzen
die form des bauteils bleibt erhalten
es wird jedoch dabei ein wenig kleiner mit seinem startup will kurz seine technologie jetzt auf den markt bringen platz zwei
effektivere therapien im kampf gegen den krebs der therapeutische nutzen von chemotherapeutika ist begrenzt die nebenwirkung sind
gravierend denn die wirkstoffe greifen nicht nur die krebszellen sondern auch gesundes gewebe an
dominik schumacher hat eine idee entwickelt bei der die entsprechenden
wirkstoffe tatsächlich erst dann aktiviert werden wenn sie auch wirklich auf eine krebszelle treffen so werden die gesunden zellen nämlich geschont und
ausgespart antrieb basiert auf dem schon existierenden
sogenannten antibody drug com uk csi verfahren verbindung zwischen
antikörpern und medikamenten die eigentlich nur die krebszellen angreifen die er selbst aber noch einmal optimiert hat denn bislang
gab es ein großes problem mit diesen adc die verbindung zwischen antikörper und wirkstoff waren viel zu instabil
schumacher setzt ein bestimmtes enzym namens too bulin
tyrosin liga sein was besonders
stabile adc erzeugt dazu der forscher damit wird verhindert dass der wirkstoff im blutkreislauf des patienten
freigesetzt wird mit seinem startup will schumacher diese technologie jetzt auf den markt bringen und damit dem krebs den kampf ansagen platz eins
vernünftiges und lukratives recycling von elektroschrott
bei der aufarbeitung und dem recycling von elektroschrott werden staubsauger oder it geräte oder oder in super kleine stücke
zerschreddert in ein granulat und aus diesem granulat werden aluminium kupfer und eisen abgeschieden das problem das ist längst nicht alles
20 bis 25 prozent bleiben derzeit über
einiges davon geht dann unter tage weil es mit schadstoffen belastet ist und in einigen ländern der welt landet es immer noch
und das ist sehr traurig auf gewöhnlichen deponie der fraunhofer-forscher peter hense hat ein verfahren entwickelt das deutlich sinnvoller und
lukrativer ist bei dem so genannten
verfahren wird aus den schredder rückständen ein metall konzentrat gewonnen das enthält dann auch noch silber kupfer
gold oder platin gruppen metalle auch die rückgewinnung versorgungs kritische high tech metalle wie tantal oder indium wird
so möglich gemacht chlorhaltige abfälle werden genutzt um das sehr seltene metall indium aus flachbildschirm oder
monitoren zu recyceln der kunststoff dagegen wird zu einer art diesel oder gas was vor ort
verbrannt wird um den prozess mit energie zu versorgen
das öl kann dann genutzt werden um wärme oder elektrische energie zu gewinnen konkret basiert das verfahren auf einem
wärmeaustauscher in schneckenform der mit hilfe eines metallischen wärme fluids die schredder rückstände auf ungefähr
650 grad celsius erhitzt das passiert in mehreren stufen unter
sauerstoff abschluss dadurch wird der kunststoff in kurze kohlenstoff ketten zerlegt ohne eben zu verbrennen weil es kein sauerstoff gibt zudem
entstehen wie gesagt gas und öl bei den schadstoffen wie etwa den prämierten und chlorierten voran und dioxin
lag das hauptaugenmerk von peter hense sie werden in diesem verfahren auf konzentrationen kommen die unter den gesetzlichen grenzwerten
liegen hensels angaben zufolge sogar zum teil sogar unter der nachweisgrenze
und auch wirtschaftlich gesehen soll das ganze sinn machen das verfahren produziert ein metall konzentrat dass sich für
800 bis
2600 euro pro tonne an kupferhütten
verkaufen lässt vielen dank an technology review in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion dieser wirklich absolut coolen zeitschrift ist dieses video entstanden
und exklusiv für klicks um zuschauer habe ich jetzt ein geschenk
ihr bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe gratis wenn ihr auf diesen link liegt das lohnt sich richtig das sind noch mehr hammer themen drin
ja und da drunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
smarthome die zukunft des lebens bis dann
bleibt dran